in our new series medical price roulette
we've teamed up with clear health costs
to see why Americans are paying
dramatically different prices for the
same medical procedures today
investigative consumer correspondent
anna warner focuses on how insurance
companies and providers keep some
charges a secret anna what did you find
right we're going to talk about this
through the lens of one young woman who
learned the hard truths about the
healthcare system when she was just a
teenager I am 15 years old I know that's
not that old but I at least I should
have some say in what I want being done
to me that was Morgan Gleason five years
ago already speaking out about health
care I am the patient and I need to be
heard and these are all my morning pills
now 21 she's learned a lot about the
system through her own journey Gleason
suffers from a disease called juvenile
dermatomyositis which causes severe
muscle weakness treatment requires
expensive infusion therapy once a month
in a hospital if you couldn't get those
what would what would that mean for you
I mean not to sound morbid or anything
but I could die but as a budding health
activist it was the payments for those
monthly infusions that caught her
attention it was mind-blowing to me it
was just shocking shocking because she
discovered insurance companies paid
different amounts for the same procedure
Gleason is covered under her parent's
insurance which over a year changed
three times for each infusion the
hospital billed roughly the same amount
around $29,000 in June 2018 records show
Cigna paid a negotiated rate of just
over $3,300 for that procedure then in
December 2018 Blue Cross Blue Shield
Alabama paid a different negotiated rate
just over $3,800 yet in February this
year insurance company GEHA paid five
times as much nearly $21,000 there was
$17,000 more $17,000 more was yes pill I
was like how is this even possible like
the only thing that's changed has been
what insurance I have that difference
affected the cost to her parents -
Gleason says the price they paid went
from about $220 out-of-pocket to more
than $4,000 under the different
insurance plans for the same procedure
at the same hospital there's no rhyme or
reason to it doctor and health services
researcher Aaron Carroll says it's all
about the price negotiations between
hospitals and insurance companies deals
he says are done in secret they don't
want everyone to know the information
because why not well because if everyone
knows the price then everybody can say I
want that price not letting everybody
else know someone else is getting a
discount is a good way to get some
people to pay more money ashley Thompson
is with the American Hospital
Association
why don't hospitals make it public what
those deals actually are with the
insurance companies hospitals don't
expose privately negotiated rates it's a
competitive market it's a private market
and and both hospitals and insurers
believe it should remain that way but if
it was public if consumers knew those
prices and could understand them better
wouldn't that help again I mean I think
that what consumers really want to know
is what they're gonna pay out-of-pocket
but even figuring that out can be a real
challenge as New Jersey's Beth toefl
knows three years ago she wound up
paying four thousand dollars for cardiac
tests after insurance it's a lot of
money and it's a lot of money when
you're already spending money on
insurance she needs those tests again
but this time she's calling around to
check prices and let us listen in can
you tell me what they would run this
time they told her they didn't know the
price she would have to speak to the lab
so I'm trying to find out approximately
what the tests will run the lab told her
to call the financial counselor hi
Gladys this is Beth toefl calling it
went to voicemail
two hours later she was no closer to an
answer than when she started I think
that's what happens I think people
either probably give up they don't
understand half of what they were told
and maybe they don't get the care they
need TOEFL is still working on getting
those tests
we reached out to the insurance
companies in this story only Cigna
responded saying it empathizes with
police in this situation but said it's
important for people to realize that
health care costs vary and they're right
so to share the prices the varying
prices you've paid go to CBS news.com
slash health costs you can also see what
others paid in our sample cities share
your prices with us subtitle subtitle of
this series is Anna makes us angry makes
your blood boil and to hear the hospital
say we don't want you to have this
information yeah well you know they're
saying look it's a private market and
they think it works a certain way and
that if you they actually say that if
the insurance companies say that if if
you expose the prices they think the
prices will go up yeah yeah the
insurance industry's position well
people want to know the end cause
there's transparency in almost every
other industry now there needs to be
transparency in this one
go to CBS news.com it's well it's never
good in an interview when the person
goes again dadadada done what you're
saying is again I heard you but I don't
know understand what you're saying yeah
I'm trying to understand supposing
prices things worse especially when
you're dealing with bills that basically
can bankrupt people yeah you know I do
you Anna Anna thank you very much